Are there supplements you would generally recommend for someone who has had their thyroid removed, would I and I be one of them?
So if you've had your thyroid removed, now lots of times when you had your thyroid removed, they didn't remove all of it, so you'd want to discover that.
Number two, if you've had your thyroid removed, you definitely are on some sort of synthetic thyroid supplementation.
Maybe it's not synthetic, maybe you're an armor, but you can't survive without thyroid hormone very well and you will have to be taking thyroid hormone the rest of your life.
Now, still, could a person with no thyroid survive a desiccated thyroid, which is a supplement technically, probably not very well, but it could, you know, even desiccated a good desiccated thyroid like our echo thyroid 37 or our clear thyroid 37 is through PHP is just a straight desiccated thyroid.
It doesn't have anything else in there, a lot of thyroid supplements out there put a bunch of other vitamins in there and methylated bees and all this kind of stuff because they want to just try to oversell the supplement is this perfect thyroid supplement, I don't like those.
So the desiccated thyroid that's solely desiccated thyroid, that's what I like best for thyroid.
Because a person with thyroid issues often has thyroid issues because they have Hashimoto's or maybe they had Graves disease, that's why they got the thyroid removed or they had a thyroid cancer, they got their thyroid removed.
And you're going to have, you know, you have this, this cold morbidity of habit in autoimmune disease, which already redisposes you to hypersensitivity to triggers that could make your condition worse.
So I like more simple supplements in the case of that where you're only got one thing in there and especially with a desiccated glandular when you're trying to support the thyroid, I would say that.
So think of a desiccated thyroid could be a possibility, would I suggest iodide if you've had your thyroid removed? No, that makes no sense whatsoever.
The only reason why a person would even conceive of taking iodide is that iodide makes up part of your thyroid needs iodide to make part of the T3 molecule which is the act of thyroid hormone.
But there's a lot of misunderstandings about iodide. So most people that are taking iodide should not even be taking iodide even if they have a thyroid. So I'm not a fan of taking exogenous iodide even if you haven't had your thyroid removed.
And there's an entire section in the autoimmune course on this, the chronic disease and autoimmune course, the module six is all about the thyroid. So you can go into depth about that.
So back to the question, are there supplements that I would recommend generally if someone had their thyroid removed?
The only thing is to continue to support your beneficial thyroid, your beneficial T3 and T4 levels. So get in your T3, T4 levels checked to make sure they're within fairly normal range with your current thyroid medication, whether you're taking a synthetic T3, synthetic T3, T4 mix or synthetic T4.
There's a bunch different thyroid medications that would give you those options. And if you've landed on one that seems to be working fairly well with you and you have your numbers fairly well in balance but you still are having thyroid symptoms.
So you can have normal in range T3, T4, free T3, free T4, reverse T3, and you're still having thyroid low thyroid symptoms. That's very common. Well then you can supplement with a desiccated thyroid and to symptomatically to help boost thyroid levels to for functional.
You can also use thyroid levels in your body. So hopefully that answers that. You use desiccated thyroid to supplement your medication if you've had your thyroid removed completely.
You still can use desiccated thyroid supplement to help supplement if you're on a medication like armor or scythroid or whatever you're on to help supplement and balance out your need because you need thyroid hormone throughout the day, depending on your stress level of the day.
It's not a perfect science of, oh, I got down to ex micrograms of ex and ex medication and it's perfect for me. I said no thyroid patient ever. It was perfect for a period of time and then they feel to crash. How come I'm having still my hair fall out? How come I'm just still tired all the time? How come I have weight getting or what is wrong with me?
I went to the doctor and my blood tests were normal because functionally you're on a daily basis, your need for hormone. It's not just steady state. It depends on your level of stress, depends on your level of physical stress and your hormone need.
You have to supplement with desiccated thyroid to help boost up where you're missing. Some days with the desiccated product you might take two of omidae and some days you might take six, some days you might take none.
So it varies depending upon your need for that day but I would never recommend iodine.